we've gone through a lot sadly in 2020
one thing has remained the same
the sheer utter incompetence the
cowardice of liberal politicians that
run all these big states they've been
running them for decades American cities
all across this great country it is now
more obvious than ever how bad they are
now we've had to face this year the
worst global pandemic in a hundred years
Donald Trump he's swell signing 10 days
after the first known case a corona
virus a travel ban and a quarantine
which we haven't had in 50 years but the
harsh realities now of this country's
economy being shut down we've been
feeling it we had great news what week
Friday ago when in fact not only were
they off they were off by about 11
million in terms of jobs that they
thought would be lost when we had 2.5
million state governors they provided
zero solutions during this pandemic they
were totally unprepared totally
incompetent and they turned to President
Trump to save them the guy that they
hate but he couldn't save even the most
vulnerable in our society the elderly
those with underlying condition from the
idiocy of actually sending Kovan 19
positive patients into nursing homes New
York did it New Jersey did it
Pennsylvania governor's they all did it
all these governors they ordered these
long-term care facilities nursing homes
to take in Cova 19 patients tens of
thousands of American lives could have
been saved and by the way that insult to
injury here that had all the hospital
bills available for them built by the
president man by the president converted
to Cova 19 capability and changing the
ventilators by the president although
all the ventilators all the ventilation
systems all change all the PPE all given
to them by Donald Trump then on May 25th
we watched in horror what was it
7 minutes 55 seconds and it went on
longer the video that shocked the
conscience and soul of this great
country it shook this country rightly to
its core we witnessed many peaceful
protests across the country in response
to George Floyd's death but we also
experienced deadly riots in America's
major cities because once the
again city and state governments almost
all of them not almost totally
unprepared and totally incompetent yet
again we see looting we see arson we see
violence we see death we see destruction
we see lawlessness
and anarchy innocent people over 20 have
died businesses destroyed we watch
police precincts burned to the ground
and these democratic mayors and
governors they have done nothing to stop
this in fact many Democrats actually are
supporting the anarchy oh and it gets
probably as bad as you can get listen to
what this congressional candidate this
genius had to say take a look we could
go in the snipers on roof it's noise on
the roof floor and a peaceful march even
if people loot so water burn it to the
ground you know if that's what it's
gonna take to fix our nation I don't
think we need to say that but I'm just
saying these politicians have run their
states and their own cities into the
ground even before the riots violent
crime in almost every major city was on
the rise their educational systems have
been failing for decades they never do a
thing to fix it and now by the way and
their taxes are higher than ever and you
see a mass exodus almost out of almost
all these cities and once again a big
liberal city has completely now lost
control of what is a critical situation
if you think watching well police
precincts burned look what's going on in
Seattle it is so bad a bizarre group of
these loosely affiliated anarchists and
other losers have literally now taken
over a six city blocks in one of
Seattle's most prominent neighborhoods
dozens of homes now under siege without
any police protection a police precinct
is now under anarchist control governor
Inslee what are you doing nothing up to
this point and by the way the president
has been begging all of these big cities
I will send in help but you have to ask
for it they steadfastly refused to do
what is right protect their citizens
protect property protect the innocent in
fact one of the first things these
far-left radicals actually did
shockingly they actually built the
border wall wow I guess walls
work is that what the message is here
armed vigilantes are now setting up
checkpoints into and out of the so
called
autonomous zone buildings inside the
zone are getting vandalized business
owners there are reports as they're
being extorted fights are breaking out
people are being assaulted and an entire
police precinct totally abandoned and
taken over by the anarchists six blocks
of pure anarchy inside the great United
States of America now I don't know about
you but I don't think I ever imagined
we'd be seeing all of this in this great
country of ours now didn't think I'd see
if it was happening they didn't do
anything to protect innocent people
either ABC News is calling this living
nightmare look get this a festive zone
that's right according to ABC quote
police in Seattle have largely withdrawn
from a neighborhood where protesters
have created a festival like scene that
has President Donald Trump fuming now
the real problem for anyone with eyes to
see in a functioning brain is that
Seattle's Democratic mayor Washington's
Democratic governor they're doing
nothing to protect their people and
restore order protecting life protecting
property the citizens of Seattle now are
literally in danger and we're watching
it in real time and these democratic
so-called leaders they're doing nothing
to protect the citizens of their state
their City looking the other way as a
group of idiot anarchists destroy their
own City now just listen for example to
the Seattle's assistant police chief
this kind of shocked me from earlier
today take a listen to be clear we did
not pull the police officers out of the
area we are still responding that I want
one cause we are still responding to
life safety emergencies
what we did was board up the windows of
the building in an attempt to secure it
from any incendiary devices being thrown
through the window or from anyone making
injury in setting a fire now today the
president responded to the chaos in
Seattle during an interview with our
very own harris faulkner he really has
to say if there were more toughness you
wouldn't have the kind of devastation
that you had in Minneapolis and in
Seattle I mean let's see what's going on
and I will tell you they don't
straighten that
we're gonna straighten it out now the
presidents right now the protesters in
the autonomous zone are holding the six
city blocks hostage unless a list of
demands are now met including things
like pre college tuition and rent
control